I think today was a proof that we can
speak very constructively about
sensitive issues such as migration and
writes an obligation the presidency had
put this issue on the agenda because we
think this is leading to what I would
call a stress test in almost all of our
societies no member state has a monopoly
on virtue or vice and the rule of law
requires therefore ongoing efforts of
all of us and self-reflection first of
all we agreed that yes this is a
fundamental issue that we also have to
talk about together it's a national
sovereignty but what happens in can in
one country has also a consequence in
other countries you can only fulfill
your rights on non-discrimination or the
rights of freedom and freedom of
association if there is also a package
of integration I think what came out of
this discussion is that we learned from
each other and we are in the process of
making a catalog of good experience how
you can do this the best from you know
the education of Imams to the issue of
education to the issue of strengthening
our our social fabric and also avoiding
the stigmatization of specific
communities we also said that there are
obligations obviously also of people who
live with us in terms of respecting the
rule of law respecting issues of
non-discrimination respecting the role
of women respecting non discrimination
on the basis of sexual orientation and
so on so forth we made a distinction
also between integration and
assimilation and my conclusion from this
dialogue is first of all yes the
European Union can discuss a sensitive
issue like this among the member states
yes it we can become very specific in
terms of rights and obligations the
input of this discussion will be part of
the communication of the European
Commission on this issue secondly I've
asked the permanent representatives to
make sure that we have clearly
in a list of lessons learned so to speak
of efforts to relate rights and
obligations towards our values when we
talk about the issue of migrants and
asylum seekers I think it's the second
important element and thirdly I've also
asked and all the minister asks the slow
worker presidency to also pursue this
dialogue and when they evaluated see
also how we can strengthen it in order
to clarify that when we talk about
social norms and human rights that this
is also a topic that is not secondary to
the European Union but in fact is at the
heart of it